honest trailers what Tuesday for the
movie that had so much hype because it
made a lot of money but no one really
talks about the movie but they really
just talk about is how much money it
made all five of those number one
weekend's oh man it's Jumanji welcome to
the jungle the movie they thought would
ruin your 90's childhood but didn't
let's check it out from the studio that
just can't seem to launch a franchise
that ended up being really fun and
something I wouldn't mind seeing more
welcome to the jungle forgot Allah in
1995 original now the reboot is tossing
out the setting the premise the dead
kids the Robin Williams and pretty much
everything except the name
[Music]
but since I swore blood off to see every
movie The Rock makes there we are me
four teenagers who are all unique and a
breakfast Kobe kind of way watch them
just like The Breakfast Club thanks to
an action-packed day in detention just
like that other it was called Power
Rangers you must be bully of the tension
grill as each team an avatar that
represents their character are the nerd
needs courage the jaw kun eats humility
the weirdo needs confidence and the
popular girl who needs to learn how a
penis words all do with this girl tied
zipper give it hard Kevin Hart Kevin
Hart's
entered you monitor or dated it's up for
a new generation that's sort of a riff
on the tropes of videogames I think he's
an NPC very it's working it drops the
pretense to be a normal adventure movie
again I got away
you lost him in the jungle wait why are
they ABC's talking to each in a jungle
scripted event
dr. Britto Jumanji needs you you know
the characters you know if Mario was
real he'd never stop screaming Jack
Black finally returns to the jungle just
can't get another way about a third
chapter of a secret jungle quadrilogy
that's a pure so as dwayne johnson
spends an entire moon discovering the
joys of be dwayne johnson whether it's
his arms
realizing he has no weaknesses the
second least qualified president someday
[Laughter]
pay proper respect to the original mrs.
allan parishes house I'm just living in
it and reminded every studio they would
most of your reboots feature-length
comedies and video game movies are
terrible will slob all over you just are
showing basic confidence story
rocky player one taaha why
happy tenacious Ong Amy respond
American Harry Styles really too many
cooks the game the movie the reboot the
videogame good news scam you've got him
on the ropes
yay go us Oh No
hey screen junkies want to avoid board
your life click the Box in the web to
explore our new show smash here for more
because we cannot it's a worldwide race
hippos face I'm actually deep-voiced
woman like ready player one y'all that's
right I think this movie has a solid
Hollywood script like when they're
talking about the archetype took The
Breakfast Club and then they take on
their avatars it might be very familiar
a little generic it's a good Hollywood
screenplay that's all this movie really
is a solid Hollywood comedy that's all I
ever expected it to film I mean it's
it's that seems to be the new thing is
let's take this thing we need to read
its crash it into a different movie
everybody likes in the new horror cap
and I agree with them about the funny
tropes about the video games when
they're when they're making where
they're doing like a play on how video
games are yeah I wish there was actually
more of that that was something that I
felt was kind of intermittent I felt
like it could have been a cool gag that
just kept coming up I'm a little bit
more frequently because when they were
doing those kind of commentaries that's
when I enjoyed it the most
I get why there might not have been so
many of them but it would have been nice
and I do think it was a good note when
they point out like why are we cutting
to just videogame characters talking to
each other plausibly perhaps they could
be but if this is like a real video game
they wouldn't need to be unless they're
with the big I mean what they could have
done is they could have cut to it and
then they could have made it go in a
letterbox yeah felt like you're watching
like a cutscene yeah that might have
been a way to help justify it a little
bit better or as a joke for in there
that's so true they said about the rocks
jungle movies
yeah I didn't even think about journey
to and the riccati did journey to and I
thought that was a funny thing to point
out like half the movies just learning
all the pleasures of being the rock I
even think about it vocally there it is
the rockers characters the keener gets
to discover being the rock what's that
Jack Black thing
oh the pitfall commercial yeah he did
way way back he did a commercial for a
video game called pitfall he used to be
skinny yeah he used to be a child never
he used to be a child who did wasn't
extremely overweight I didn't know that
too many cooks guy was in that did you
notice him I didn't notice him I think I
did I've seen him popping up here and
there and stuff so if it wasn't Jumanji
it was something else recent that kind
of scares me I know right because using
like an extra featured extra at best so
you are like half expecting things to
bring it start you know messing up and
him starting to kill people or whatever
that's right it's that's pretty crazy to
me that Adam in there that's so true
Kevin Hartz the only one who play it's
just Kevin Hart who they yeah yeah you
think about the character they was
before detention he's like he didn't
have anywhere near this much energy you
like what would you really want to see
Kevin Hart play anyone else not in this
kind of movie at all but I mean I never
want to seek if he does or something and
I mean he's already got such an
established presence with the rocks well
that was a funny honest trailer guys I
feel like honors trailers gonna be
harder to do when they're making fun of
comedies so when they when they
successfully make a funny on this
trailer off of a comedy you know and you
go to an improv show I mean like a John
recalls give me a John audience and some
[ __ ] goes I feel like that's
challenge here alright guys so you can
subscribe and become part of the reject
nation today and click that notification
because subscribe buttons are pointless
also check us out on other stuff
you